yeah welcome to this video um g3 yeah
it's a booth Mary try for the reversed
grown pre here this is one of the
strange cases where the the reverse
version is actually better than the the
original version yeah this is quite an
interesting gambit and why them needs to
be very cautious to not get into instant
trouble the best movie is d3 yeah now I
can get the port back but there's simply
not nothing terrible happening to white
and this can actually happen in other in
other lines 92 is so somewhat rare yeah
no no not before I think you can
probably play d4 so just continue to
develop
yeah I'm a bit late with castling before
as a good move really only saw this now
don't want to waste more time with
retreating or something and maybe I
could have my ID for night before that
was that was that was a default yeah
this is very ambitious to get the bishop
he and the only thing I got wow really
ok put bit surprised him I didn't think
that this would be any any problem and
every thought I should be in some
trouble it looked like something was
wrong in this position and this son
looks fairly am ok now I'd say
yeah it isn't dumb d3 just week d3 and
III I don't look like the healthiest
pawns ever yeah I probably need to at
some point mrs. spawn I don't like to
put them on light squares but whatever
look the eyedropper t7s open what I want
to play put pressure on the depot now
Brooke the eighth and rook f.2d seven
yeah I'm not sure what you should do
it's not an easy defense you had this
the sound you can do dad mmm yeah this
is actually interesting an interesting
decision I'm sorry bit of a sore throat
the questions i couldn't i can actually
take it it's not bad and because the sea
for this week I can let's do this this
is one of those keep it simple moments
maybe not the most ambitious way to play
wit for once I got a slide slide them on
edge on the clock so to try to play
quickly at least not try to fall behind
on the clock this was one of the ideas
that the sea for porn is son ism
possible points to attack okay roop c5
he's just going to play beat three
ok I'd like to get rid of one of those
rocks okay if i go here is stupid
okay maybe I can provoke this and then
return to then try to attack be 30 end
zone a2 b2 something like that
yeah I think I'm not risking anything
he's got this entry is squared d 7 but
this is always covered by the knight on
f6 Dwight is really in sort of yeah
cannot do much position so nice if for
another still rock f1 key assemblies got
rookie successes I wait I can go to g8
check and no i don't i don't know dad
maybe maybe debt to get here this is my
bean idea how to how how does he uh this
one
yeah okay did didn't really make
anything out of this not sure how much
it wasn't the first place but this is
certainly certainly nothing I could have
taken here ok let's take no ok ok oh I
didn't really see it was hanging oh this
is stupid oboe he's trapping his own
rook Knight f3 was also possible but
this is just the rook why it takes on
must take only five now and maybe the
check was better I know what I was just
too fascinated by the rook trap
sasukes 19
like reason yeah this was of course just
to give ya just to give it yeah i
blundered e5 like it just blundered e5
away I thought I can I can if I first
wanted to take and then move the king
and then it's probably and just just a
draw but i had to simply didn't see that
if I things yeah I think I had to add a
little bit of something here just really
a little bit but I thought there should
be possible it used to to get something
round here those pawns are simply a bit
looser than mine now they are not
protected and anyway and blacks are
protected and it's nothing yeah computer
is sometimes very logical rookie to a 8
yeah this is a good move this thing is
just doing nothing besides protecting a
poem that it's not attacked and for go
here I managed to to get rid of one room
yeah this is simply good some play good
move it's not a winning app or something
but it's just improving my position I
need to I can exchange a bedrock on the
eight against a useful one on b1 that at
least is protecting the weaknesses yeah
this would have been strong I'm strong
move yeah yeah this is probably a about
equal but of course not after i er I
gave the pawn away it offers some
chances to fight because it is at the
moment located located lockdown but then
he went for this self rook trap
interneta to simply gone yeah just very
very lucky yeah thanks for watching